now regarding rogan this is
somebody found remember when you brought
it up to me actually
when people were like you told me you
know rogan doesn't go live anymore
he pre-records his stuff wait a minute
remember when this was right around the
time he started not
going live anymore yes you want to know
why
and he started premiering streams
austria recorded him is this the uh oh
because remember this tim poole jack
dorsey
but remember this was the one that
disappeared for a while and everybody
went where did that go
and then it was back up but it was
edited
oh no did we get something and i love
this time
again this is good it's not super juicy
but you're going to see
why he's not going live anymore
it exists that's what i want to see it's
going to happen whether we like it or
not
um any last thoughts no i just want to
thank you
joe this has been great and tim thanks
for your feedback so this was the end of
the show this was all here
thank you i really appreciate you guys
thank you jack james
no i think we've said it all that's a
wrap folks no more ear beatings
good night everybody that was awesome
thank you
thank you thanks for for talking i
really do appreciate it that was great i
hate
audio i want to follow up on a couple of
things because they worry me
the you mentioned an antifa account that
doc's policeman can you please just send
that
over to me bit.ly antifa
antifa tweet and then um would you dm me
i'll follow you would you dm me the
the accounts that you said um have
threatened you no
um i believe in minimizing harm
and if i i so uh
when patreon i won't how about this i
won't take action on them but i want to
understand why we didn't take action on
them and i can't learn from that
i won't take action on it so so uh when
lauren other got banned from patreon
a lot of people were there
everybody out of the room this is
streaming and it's frozen
his streaming program froze and it was
still live
so that's the if you want to know the
reason why rogan doesn't go live anymore
that's the reason why and that that's
happened like i've had my ob i've had my
obs freeze on me and which is
because now now it's gonna this is gonna
be
for rogan it's going to be you you
peaked you're not going to get bigger
than you've been
and now you're going to slow people are
going to slowly start losing interest
you think people
are oh it's not live anymore and it's
not
you know what i mean it's too sanitary
and it's too pre-recorded so it's
yeah man it's just weird
so uh yeah it stayed recording and i
think ever since then that's the reason
i guess somebody
else must have sniped it hey listen tim
guy who's now part of the inner circle
could you give me a list of these people
and don't worry we'll get them for you
yeah to be fair no into tim's defense
he's like you know we gotta keep
i gotta get by the way by the way people
could say you're phony but he didn't
know he was lying
he didn't know i was gonna say he didn't
know he was live so that's not tim cool
you know [ __ ] putting on a front door
cool for the part like he was literally
hey can you give us a list of the people
that are asking
no you got i got look you gotta give him
that much that
that is at least the man who was
principled because even offer he was
like no
no i don't know i i'm not good with that
i don't know i'm not a snitch
yeah i know that's dog snitch i know
snitch dog i knew tim was that gangster
yeah i didn't know either but that's the
reason ever since that rogan hasn't been
um
rogan hasn't been going live because of
that little
tim gave my respect with that i really
because when she was like can you give
me a list
i was waiting for him to be like yeah
sure but he was literally like no
no no i'm not it's not happening